the crown is a political which means it
is above politics
therefore acting as a unifying factor
between the four independent nations
which make up this United Kingdom what
Republicans want is someone actually
doing what monarchies claim the Queen
does so someone who is independent who
is elected by the people to do that job
clearly the monarchy is elitist the
monarchy doesn't allow any opportunity
to even things out or to create a more
egalitarian society because it instills
in our culture and in our institutions
this notion that certain people are born
into privilege and power I would say
this is absolutely a fallacy on their
part Her Majesty is there in her duty
and capacity as sovereign to award
people for services and duty to crown
and country rewarding people for what
they are not for how much they have in
their bank
people come to Buckingham Palace simply
for the fact that it means something
Her Majesty is a living breathing
embodiment of the crown of the state and
it means more when they see the changing
of the guard people obviously enjoy the
heritage in the history and they want to
come and see the palace and the the
castles this is a debate about democracy
and about politics and about power then
we shouldn't be basing our Constitution
on what people find entertaining on the
olivine
I understand for a lot of monarchists
that this is this is a heartfelt
position and that it comes down to their
sense of you know what Britain is their
sense of identity Britain is more than
the monarchy we have to reimagine that
identity that doesn't include a fairly
grubby political stitch-up
that has been perpetuated by one family
in the service of the politicians I
respect their position because it must
be difficult to be a minority not
believing in your system of government I
would ask to respect the history respect
who we are through the crown
you